the idea of an actor fluffing up their
resume with unreal skills might sound
like something out of a sitcom but
plenty of actors have been caught
red-handed here's a fond look back at a
few of those major actors who've lied to
get the big part it's hard to believe
that a hunk like Chris Hemsworth who has
flexed both his massive muscles and his
funny bone as the Asgardian god of
thunder for in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe would ever have to lie in order
to persuade casting directors to give
him a role just as Hemsworth surprised
us with his comedic timing and thor
ragnarok he shocked fans when he
admitted to radio times that he used to
lie about his height of all things to
get more work the six foot three Aussie
admitted there are certainly things I've
wanted to go up for which I've been
totally wrong for physically and I
normally lie about my height and say I'm
shorter but it can go two ways the
briefer the audition for Thor said must
be over 6 foot 1 inch which I'd never
seen before to score the role of Queen
drummer Roger Taylor and the Brian
singer directed biopic Bohemian Rhapsody
Ben hardy got caught up in his own
little fantasy party really wanted the
job and told singer what he called a big
lie about his drumming skills in hopes
of getting hired for the film having
previously collaborated with singer for
x-men apocalypse party sent the director
and email inquiring about Bohemian
Rhapsody and asking quote in the nicest
way possible
if singer thought he could be in the
film hardy told people I told singer I
could play the drums which I couldn't at
the time singer asked Hardy to record
himself drumming to a song to show the
producers and Hardy panicked but then he
got to work pretty shitty that's good
I bought the cheapest drum kit I could
find and found a drum teacher locally
and was like look here's the deal I need
to learn to play this song as soon as
possible what can you do luckily for
Hardy his lie and his training paid off
big-time it's hardly a secret that
Robert Pattinson has doctored his resume
in the past falsely claiming that he
attended Oxford University and London's
illustrious drama school the Royal
Academy of Dramatic Arts as a way to
score roles after moving to America but
alongside that deceit he also lied about
his nationality in order to make himself
more marketable to Hollywood big shots
as Pattinson confessed to the Daily
Mirror I lied about my education for
years but it didn't work when loads of
English people started movie
to Los Angeles so then I pretended to be
American for a bit desperate times call
for desperate measures and in the case
of character actor todd lawson
LaTourette a difficult situation drove
him to do the unthinkable an amputee and
self-described war veteran LaTourette
built a satisfactory career in film and
on television using his missing hand and
the trauma of his past to inform his
approach to roles how exactly did you
lose it I was riding shotgun in a Humvee
in Kandahar they drove right over an iud
casting directors liked what they saw
and tapped him for parts and films like
the men who stare at goats beard for my
horses and a television series including
Longmire and the acclaimed Breaking Bad
spinoff better call Saul where he made a
blink and you'll miss it appearance but
LaTourette scre ear was founded on a lie
in November 2018 he revealed that he'd
been dishonest about being a war veteran
and that he didn't lose his hand while
serving overseas the truth of the matter
is arguably even grimmer 17 years before
LaTourette experiencing what he
described as a psychotic episode during
a time he was off his medication meant
to manage his bipolar disorder severed
his own hand with a saw his lie worked
but the guilt was too much to bear so
LaTourette decided to come clean i was
dishonorable i'm killing my career by
doing this if anybody wants to think
this was for personal edification it's
not the case Laurence Fishburne is done
at all from scoring an Academy Award
nomination for his performance as Ike
Turner and what's love got to do with it
the dipping his toes into the DC
extended universe and the MCU Fishburne
is something of a legend but he's also a
little bit of a liar too as the actor
FIB to director Francis Ford Coppola so
he could star in Apocalypse Now in 1976
so then 14 year-old Fishburne told
Coppola he was actually 16 in efforts to
boost his chances at landing the role of
17-year old Tyrone mr.clean Miller
Coppola bought the lie and cast
Fishburne in the war epic which was
famously fraught with production issues
by the time the film finally debuted in
theaters in May of 1979 Fishburne was
actually as old as his character
[Music]